that's nice
it never gets old does it never does
[Laughter]
you should at least pretend it gets old
sometimes it doesn't get old doesn't get
on a pretense you walk into a pizza
parlor and everybody doesn't
stand up i've never eaten a pizza in my
life
you've never had a pizza we gotta get
you a pizza
would you stop making noise over there
he just hit his tambourine anyway good
rocking tonight was a great
thing they did a good job didn't they
they're great band you're lucky
well i think they're lucky to work with
a man of my talent and ability
okay that was embarrassing uh first of
all i i
we've talked before you know that i'm
one of those people that knows
more about you than you know about you i
do
yeah it's i'm one of those people that
has the the books and the
bootlegs and the rare bootleg unreleased
of you guys
tuning your instruments and sleeping and
making
chili and you must it must be kind of
weird to meet people like me because
it's like you just lived your life and
you did these great things but
it's just your life yes but i have to
rely on people like you now
why is that i have no memory well you
you forgot everything everything so i
can tell you that on march 5th 1968
you had an amazing bagel yeah um
no there there really is i mean for
example there are these
uh i think there's one isn't it this
week frank that there's a there's one of
these uh
beatles conventions where all the people
come together and it borders on
craziness
i haven't gone to those but it borders
on craziness where
they have soap that's of your head and
they're praying to it
let me tell you i've never been to one
either you've never gone to a beatles
convention but
uh a lot of people who do go say they
have a good time oh that's good
uh the only problem i have with it that
a lot of the stuff they're selling
is sort of stuff from now and it's not
like the old stuff
right it's like they make a guitar and
right or they say this is an actual and
they make my head out of soap
actually i did that uh
i'm curious you have been super super
famous now
for uh for over 40 years
uh uh you know i think about being
famous
longer than you've been on this planet
it's true that's actually a true
statement you're 35 now right
i'm 28. actually but you're very close
and i'm getting it tomorrow next year
i'll be
i'll be 25 next year you're looking
forward to that no uh
you uh and you think about it i was
thinking you can you even remember
when you weren't ringo starr when you
were just richard starkey normal guy
walking around
do you remember being richard starkey a
normal fella
i'm i'm thinking you're thinking you
always nod your head like that
i'm thinking because that's a real
problem don't point out my problem
okay let's talk about my job anyway yeah
it was a long time ago and of course my
family
you know my children don't say hey ringo
do you want a cup of tea
right they uh say hi dad and darling
i called you darling earlier and you
didn't like it i wasn't going to mention
it
um it was very nice of you
you're you once said to your mother i
read this at an interview you once said
to your mother
all people over the age of 60 should be
shot yes
i used to think as a teenager anyone at
60 should be shot
they were just taking up space on the
planet right
so i'm just curious how old are you now
time to be shot
[Laughter]
let's not have that i still have that
but anyway the other line my mother
when i was 40 my mother who remembered
everything
uh as mothers do said when i was 14 a
happy birthday son
i don't suppose you still think like you
used to about 60 year olds and i said no
not anymore mom
it was funny at the time
[Laughter]
how do we have proof you have to be you
can look it up in a book uh
what do you think of these days there's
this phenomenon
where pop stars don't come up
the way the beatles came up where it was
a very organic
experience there are pop groups that are
put together
uh and they're sort of packaged uh there
are shows like american idol which
began in england and has come over here
and become a big success are you
comfortable with that phenomenon i don't
i don't take much of an interest in it i
mean i come from as you said i come from
first of all getting your instrument
then playing with friends
playing in clubs playing in theaters
playing in our case
stadiums right um where you know i play
for the joy of playing
my dream was to play drums which i do
and to play with good players and then
playing with great players which i still
am
so you know my dreams are still coming
true and i'm still playing so that's
good
the ones they put together i i don't
understand it really because
you put like five strangers in the room
you tell them what to sing uh some
producer will take a line from that one
a line from this one
right they'll go on stage pretend and
they had something to do with this
right and then the minute it's not
working they just get dumped
right they also do a strange thing which
is they tell people what their
personality is
yeah you're the tough one you're the
cuddly one
whereas opponent's the tall one
i was going to go for sexy but you went
for tall
tall and sexy thank you uh that'll be
i like it when you say it
people just tuning in there oh there we
are
but it's funny because one of the things
that was so great about the experience
you went through was that
it was all organic and real everyone had
their own
identity and that came through and today
i think they would be saying
okay john we're going to make you this
one and we're going to make paul this
one and ringo that one and
it seems like a very i ever do that i'd
like them to make me taller
[Laughter]
i have a lot of pull with these um
people be sarcastic now
now you're playing a song tonight for us
which is called never without you
yes this is a tribute to george harrison
exactly um
first of all my condolences that that
this season is necessary
to do well you know the song you know
george has gone
physically but spiritually he's still
with us
through his friendship with me and his
music
so the song is about that he's still
he's still with us anyway right right
and this is uh that's got to be a
powerful thing to perform
for people i mean you know though we've
been on this role now promoting the
record ring-a-rama
and mainly play in the song
it's still an emotional moment
especially when
i've put in in the song
words that george had written uh you
know from neville
i'm having a moment you don't even know
who i
am right now yes i do
yes i do ted come back it's coming back
uh within you without you some of his
lines we put in the song
so uh all things must pass right so
you know it was for me it was a nice way
to say
you know i know you know i knew george
loved me i loved
george and this is a song for him what's
also nice is that you got
uh clapton to play on it
the only guitarist i would have on this
track because
uh they george and eric had a great
relationship right eric and i and george
and i so
i wanted him to play on the record we
called him up and he said okay
what was nice is there was this amazing
uh tribute at the
was it the royal albert hall for for
george and i think this is just a few
months ago
it was last november the 29th yeah and
it was i
i didn't wasn't able to go but everyone
told me that it had the spirit of a
party which was probably what he would
have wanted something
and all these great musicians who knew
and loved him coming together and
playing his music that's the point
everybody on stage
knew george he knew them it wasn't like
we're doing a charity let's call
conan you know
[Laughter]
i waited by the phone ringo yeah but you
know i sat by that phone for hours
waiting
now carl never came through i play a
mean mirage you know what i mean it was
old people that loved him he loved them
he
knew them so it was great that we all
played together was great and then we
all hung out together was great we all
had our george stories and
our moments so it was really a cool
thing to do
well we're thrilled that you're you're
here we're also thrilled that you're
going to play uh
this song for you it's just it's a real
joy for me when you come on the program
and it's really
i'm also really happy that you're out
there and you're making good music
and you're doing your thing and don't
forget this summer i'm on tour
he's on tour and he's also got an album
ringo rama which is out there
ringo starr he'll be back at the end of
the show we'll be right back
you